[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
hope you brought your questions
we have brought some answers and we're
going to try to match them
up ooh that could be fun yes yeah
just put them on a hat it's a twist
we've done the jeopardy thing this is
the next
logical step yep yep now we've got all
four carnivorous present at this point
we've got uh
maddie has just entered the room there
she is welcome there she is
and all three cats arguing over cream in
the background
all right we will start with four
questions
from last week's episode episode 63.
climate models aren't as bad as you say
there is physical conservation
same models are used for weather
forecasts some parameters
parameterizations are iffy um
so i included this because um i was
surprised
that we were understood to be claiming
that climate climate models were
bad across the board we are absolutely
100 not yes
what they are is iffy and what we have
said
i will take responsibility for this what
i have said is that they
are fine as the generators of hypotheses
they are not in and of themselves
tests of anything and so
yes some of the models are liable to be
quite good the question is which ones
and how do you know
and what do you do with things like the
uncertainties surrounding
cloud models and the what we discussed
last
week with respect to the negative
feedback that
might arise from
increased ocean depths resulting in
greater pressure that holds
methane clathrates frozen in the arctic
um and so in any case what you do if
you've got a model and you think it's
good
is you test what it says rather than use
it as a test
yep and actually um i meant to read
these two together from the same person
he says seeger at all 2019 showed in
science that there was an enso bias in
all climate models and so being
the el nino southern oscillation um the
field is not captured
there's plenty of disagreeable
mathematicians which i'm sure um
so yeah i don't know i did not go and
find that paper but um
just continuing on with the same yeah
but field is not
captured it's not that simple
there is pressure to
not deviate in other words we can see
because of what happens
when we as non-climate scientists say
that we have skepticism about any part
of what we hear from
climate uh science we get pushback
yeah to believe that that pushback does
not exist inside of a field that
believes that the future of the world
rests on whether or not people accept
what it says it results in an artificial
uh consensus and so that has to not be
the case if people are to
um to trust what's being said from a
field and the perverse incentives are
there as they are in every other field
it's just the danger is greater in this
one yeah
next question in terms of cultural
evolution could wokeness be an
environmental stressor which serves to
strengthen enlightenment values in
society
if we survive um
yeah intermediate levels of disturbance
is what we're shooting for
right i mean look i i think you know our
joking answers here
are exactly right which is to say my
joking in group
uh you know models of explanations for
the latitudinal diversity gradient yes
yes well so
all of these things are correct yes of
course wokeness could force us to
grapple with our values and could cause
us to bring a whole new
generation online with the reasons that
those values are so important how would
it do that
by jeopardizing those values so that
people registered their loss so
yes of course it could and the question
is and that is part of what you know
that is part of what it presumably
explains at least some of the pendulum
swing
between between sets of values is that
people don't notice the erosion of them
until they you know and everyone has
some different straw that broke the
camel's back some different moment at
which like oh wait
i you know i cannot do that thing and
people before me were complaining about
these other things that i didn't care
about now i
now it's hit something that i care about
i can see it now i'm paying attention
so the potential is there um but
you know if you think about things like
um
you know this equity stuff equity in the
the bailly form the more aggressive
version uh
of the argument that is not
a viable basis for a system
we will destroy functional institutions
attempting to do that that is to say
any school any business that signs
up for this in lieu of a system of merit
will
suffer in its quality and it will fail
relative to competitors that don't sign
up for this so
you don't need to run the experiment to
discover that what could you destroy
if you decide well we're going to need
to see that for ourselves before we
accept that that version of equity
doesn't work
you could destroy the west you know
you could put china or russia or who
knows who
in a unrivaled position in
the world this is an extremely dangerous
game to play in order to rediscover
values whose basis was
well understood and captured um
in you know in literature and
discussions at the time so
yeah it you know education is not the
solution to everything but at the very
least we ought to educate ourselves on
what is understood about why these are
our values how we arrived
here and why they need to be protected
rather than run the experiment of
uninventing all of them to see why
you know so that we can rediscover them
right
and final question from last week
boy i put this on here and then i hadn't
considered it until just now so i'm not
sure what the answer is going to be what
are you personally not
doing that goes against your better
nature in the context of your biology
education
and why not right what are you
personally not doing
that goes against your better nature in
the context of your biology education
and why not like what do we know
um would be good for us
i think you know what given what we know
about biology and evolution
uh uh and we're behaving in ways that
are that are opposite
um i think uh i mean
i guess i don't think it's i don't think
we have a viable alternative which is
why
it's not um a live question for us
but i think it's perfectly clear
that the internet
its algorithms and processes are
dangerous to the quality of thought and
that we would be wise to come up with a
rigorous and regimented isolation
mechanism
we would be healthier i mean frankly
it'd probably be smarter just to walk
away from the whole thing than to engage
it as it is
um that said uh our
family's livelihood depends entirely on
interacting
and it wouldn't frankly i don't think be
fair
to people who um are
[Music]
getting something valuable out of this
so i feel like
we know it's bad for us but we don't
have a choice and that that's not
entirely irrational okay
um yeah i mean i think i have two
generic answers that would be true for
many many of the people watching and so
i think
i think there's something perhaps that
can be learned from thinking about
thinking about both of them which is you
know not
actually doing heart pumping exercise as
much
as uh as you say you want to
and do want to and always feel better
afterwards and usually feel great while
you're doing it even but
um the sort of activation energy
required to get to get suited up and out
the door
whatever it is depending on what the
activity is uh
can be um can be too high
such that you don't do uh as much you
know in the winter
like this year you are actually going
out on your bike a fair bit
and um there have definitely been
winters when you haven't
and i'm not doing it this winter and uh
and this this thing that our brains tell
ourselves in advance of hard work
um that it's easier which it is uh
to just stay where you are is
a kind of um privileging of
short-term comfort over long-term
benefit
and teaching yourself to
um actively remember um you know
especially like
engage in activity and sport and thrill
whatever it is that you actually love
and if you just hate moving your body i
don't know what to tell you
but um you know fine find
and i even hate the word exercise right
like find
some athletic enterprise that you really
do thoroughly enjoy
and um i mean there's there's certainly
benefits tons of benefit in walking but
i'm specifically talking about the kind
of thing
that you know you're going to come back
and you need to shower to feel
comfortable like you're not going to
want to just get into bed after doing
this because you're going to be
sweaty and that kind of work for
i think for actually most of us actually
feels
amazing and afterwards you feel much
better and those benefits
you know continue for days you know even
if you're doing it every day or
almost every day and yet it's very easy
to get out of the habit
because it's it's more comfortable to
sit around
so i want to add two things to that one
what usually happens when i stop doing
it over the winter
is i do it pretty regularly
until i get sick somewhere
and you know this was a much bigger
problem when we were teaching college
students and they would bring
everything through the door and our kids
were in daycare until you got experience
there was like six or seven years there
where we were both teaching college
students and our kids were in
daycare and there was just no no
avoiding the pathogens
many many colds and sometimes worse and
that you know when you're knocked off of
this pattern for a couple of weeks
or if there's a particularly bad uh
spate of weather
so that you know it's not safe to ride
your bike because there's
ice on the roads or something right and
then you try to go back to it's very
hard
to do and so in some ways this winter
has been better because we haven't been
passing the
regular colds around yeah we're not sick
um
which i think there's a you know we're
not paying attention to because we're
paying attention to covid but
we societally ought to be paying
attention to how much better we are
doing on many of these other
pathogens and we ought to figure out um
what the
lesson of that is the other thing i
wanted to say here though is
this is a place where our biology is
upending us
because our novel circumstances don't
match our ancestral circumstances
essentially the subject of our book but
the point is this
your ancestors almost all of them were
starving almost all of the time
doesn't mean they never had adequate
food but the point is to the extent that
there's excess food populations tend to
grow
and that means that they become they're
self-limiting
so what that also implies is that any
food
you don't have to source because
you are able to not spend the calories
is to your advantage which is why we are
so sensitive to it being chilly it's not
that there's anything bad about it being
chilly in fact it's probably good for
you if you have unlimited food
but we are constantly in this mode of
trying to save every calorie because
essentially
at some point those calories are the
difference between life and death and
we are programmed to save them now so
that we have them then
and that totally miswires us for
our own physiology which accumulates fat
and all of these other things where
wouldn't it be wonderful
if instead of feeling you know uh some
sort of
trepidation and resistance to going out
and doing amazing exercise that we know
is good for us
we were wired to be enthusiastic about
going out the door especially if it's
cold
you know that would be the way you know
if we could self reprogram
in order to do these things we'd be
better off but we're up against
uh programming that occurred in an
ancestral environment we no longer live
in
and so it you know yes we know it would
be better to go out and
uh do vigorous exercise more but we like
everybody else are up against
our own ancestral program programming
programming which is just out of phase
with the present
yeah that's very good um the other thing
i will say is that um despite my
ever more ever greater certainty that
these two things are just not healthy
for uh for us to be ingesting i continue
to eat sugar and drink alcohol and um
you know i
love to bake and have a sweet tooth and
and you know both of us i think you're
you have an easier time resisting sugar
although
now that i bake gluten-free it's harder
for you when i make delicious
things um and and both of us drink
and i um i am particularly compelled
that you know alcohol just
is not is not healthy it's just not good
for us and i say that you know it's
you know bad neither of us have ever
thought
or had anyone else say oh you've got a
drinking problem it's not it's not like
that it just
i can just feel much as after you do
you know rigorous exercise you feel
better your body is just more
more flexible and mobile and just
everything about it is functioning
better
after um you know right after a drink
or two you feel looser and it's it's
nice
and i you know my german irish
background i don't
to get hung over but i always feel like
less sharp and less
capable um for a little bit in the
morning the next day
um if i've had a drink or two the night
before
so um again it's
it's about prioritizing short term over
long term yeah and in fact
um we have experimented uh
quite a bit with foregoing alcohol for
periods of time
and one of the things one discovers is
that it takes a long time
for you know five o'clock to hit and for
it not to occur to you to maybe have a
drink
but if you can get through the five
minutes where it occurs to yeah maybe i
would have a drink just forget
you forget and uh so it's really a very
short-term thing you're responding to
um so in any case that's another yeah
those are good examples
all right the question from the discord
server this week is
how do we come back to shared reality
together when it seems record numbers of
people are suffering from mass
delusional conspiracy thinking on both
sides of the political spectrum
well the real question is who wants us
involved in these massive conspiracies
and how are they convincing us
to think this way all right that was
irony
that was sorry um i'm back
uh yes well here's the problem i think
really
is that the
unprecedented complexity of our
informational environment
and the collapse of the structures that
are supposed to help us make sense of it
have resulted in a kind of sense vacuum
and conspiratorial thinking is
natural because conspiracies are real
they happen they're not uncommon
and therefore speculation about what
might be the result of them is not
novel it's ancient so
the real question is um are there
conspiracies
yeah lots of them most conspiracy
hypotheses
wrong just that's automatic just as most
hypotheses about anything will be wrong
so how especially in the neighborhood of
conspiracy
does one exert some kind of quality
control
and it's not simple because the rules
that allow you to sort
truth from fiction under regular let's
say scientific
uh circumstances don't apply because a
conspiracy will by definition
try to create an explanation
for something that is false in order to
cover the true explanation it's inherent
yeah so we need to we need to do better
about this i will say
um i am in conversation with somebody
that i'm hoping to put on the podcast
soon who i regard as an expert in this
topic and we will talk about it
excellent um i guess i will also say
that
we are trying to model some of what we
do
in order to uh detect and assess
possible conspiracy hypotheses in our
midst and
um you know information that comes in
you know often it's information that
comes in
as if it is 100 true and then it turns
out that there is a motivation behind
the person who's feeding it to you so
um you know it's at some level you can't
do absolutely everything in your life
like this i remember i mean i remember
when we were in our 20s
and you know really trying to resist
just about all of the received wisdom
entirely and i remember at one point we
were like grocery shopping together
and standing like in front of the paper
towels going what kind of paper towel
should we buy
and it occurred to me like this is what
brand loyalty is for on the positive
side
like just you want you need some things
in your life that you can set and forget
right that you can just be like i just
made this choice already
you made the choice it doesn't matter
it's not that important to me right
and it's really important to the you
know eight companies who are vying for
my dollars but once i've made one just
it doesn't matter anymore right
and of course the brands themselves make
that difficult because they change it up
like you know i'd love that for
you know the shoes that i was just like
let me just buy the same shoes that i
bought
two years ago to walk around oh they
don't exist anymore oh they're only in
that hideous color oh my god like why do
i have to rethink this
again like i actually really don't want
to have to rethink most of my like
buying decisions
over and over and over again um but with
regard to
intellectual stuff there's almost
nothing that you can safely set and
forget
you actually have to say for almost
anything coming in
you know there once you trust people and
you know this is actually something that
we both used to say
in our classrooms that i would say on
the very first day i'm up here
i've got the degree that allows me to be
a college professor and you guys are all
paying tuition
and you should not trust me on that
basis i like i will be writing your
narrative evaluations at the end of the
quarter
rather than grades um but you know
maybe maybe you don't come you know i i
have to earn
your respect and your trust and if i
fail to do that
you shouldn't stay in this classroom you
shouldn't you know go into the field
with me
you should not pretend to be learning
from me which is in fact what
most students are doing at every level
is kind of you know ticking off boxes
and nodding when they're supposed to nod
and regurgitating stuff when they go to
the next class and if it's like
post-modernism and then physics well
they're at complete odds with one
another
and they're pretending in one or the
other or maybe sometimes both of them
and just
playing the how do i satisfy this
teacher game
and it's what a lot of us have begun to
do with our media as well
so being extremely skeptical of
everything that comes in
coming coming to trust and respect some
voices
that still will make errors but that you
don't have to apply the same level of
skepticism at all times too
um is um is a way to shortcut a little
bit of it
um but really whenever the whenever
claims are made like masks don't help
or the vaccines are safe the data say so
um and you know trust the science well
no that's not that's actually not how
science works
and you've just given me an indication
that i now need to go back and figure
out what it is that you're basing that
on and oh wow that was political
not scientific at all now what do i do
yeah you gotta do your own work
anybody who's robbed a bank or a
stagecoach knows that masks work
all right you're feeling a little
shortchanged at my response
yeah sorry about that the next uh so
finally before we get to questions from
today uh there was
a second discord question which is just
a suggestion that i said i would read
aloud please record a nature walk where
you discuss whatever interesting things
you see
or to make it into a question why aren't
you doing this already
[Music]
yeah well you know a i don't think we
we have not experimented very much with
um
live streaming over cellular
well let's record i'm not sure well it
wouldn't have to be live streamed
um it would be recorded either way but
um but
how awful to have your nature walk uh
built around
i mean i'm not saying there's not a
purpose to it and we could do it
especially but
um i mean i guess also so you know we've
specifically talked about
doing trips like taking people into
nature specifically the kind of deep
nature we've spent a lot of time and
where we have access that um
you know if you just buy a trip to the
amazon once that is possible again
most times you don't actually get into
anything that's really the amazons like
on the map it kind of looks like it is
but you don't actually get anywhere
close and it's really disrupted and
um you know beyond secondaries like
little forest fragments
um but
what i used to teach people how to be
animal behaviorists
and i unlike you know everyone else at
these remote field stations that i would
take people to it'd be like you must go
out alone
you absolutely must go out alone because
just you know and like oh you have to be
you know in order to be safe you have to
have a buddy it's like i haven't brought
anyone here who i don't trust and you
need to tell someone when you're leaving
and tell you
do all the backcountry safety things of
course but
if you go out with someone else and
you're trying to actually observe
animals doing what they're doing
even if you know that's what you're
trying to do when you really have your
heart in it and you're really trying to
do that
um we are social creatures and we will
end up talking
even just a little bit even in subdued
voices and
as soon as you talk the animals become
cryptic and
and either flee or just become cryptic
in place and they don't do anything
anymore
so you know if what you're looking for
is
lemon ants in the amazon for instance or
um you know socratea like you know the
walking palm or something if you're
looking for plants
or um or ants
uh you you can talk through it but if
you're looking for anything charismatic
you actually have to be totally quiet
and so
talking about what you see is going to
make what you see much
less because it will be scared off um so
potentially recording and then talking
afterwards about what
was recorded is a possibility yep yeah
there there are things you could do
um i also feel like uh it's not as
possible
right here in portland as it should be
you know
we have i would say um lots of natural
space around us but it's amazing
how um overtaken it is with english ivy
and what a big impact that has on i'm
doing what i can uh
i know here it's a big state yes um
i am doing what i can just very very
locally but it's a big project
but you know english ivy here uh in
california
um not everywhere but some places you
know
massive problem with eucalyptus and the
thing is the
effect that this has on all of the
creatures
is profound this is really um a
under recognized ecological catastrophe
biologists are aware but i think others
are you know they see
green space and they think um it's
nature and in fact
in many cases what you have is one
species or a couple of species
disrupting what would otherwise be there
at levels that are
hard to appreciate unless you saw it
happen most people who go
most portlanders i think who spend any
time in nature know that english ivy is
a scourge and they'll
recognize it when they see it but you
know i have a very hard time looking at
a landscape
that's got english iv visible in it and
not just
sort of feeling the absence of what
should be there
and um yep yeah i've
as you know i've cleared and we bought a
piece of property that was nearly
covered and i've been
you know doing a little bit every week
and
when i've cleared trees and both species
of huckleberries
and sword ferns and then we've been here
a couple years now so i've been able to
see
just you have cleared the huckleberry of
the ivy
right sorry when i when i've cleared
trees and two species of huckleberry and
uh sword foreign of the ivy um
you can actually see not for the trees
right away but you can see for the
understory stuff
um their response really
almost immediately like it's almost like
it's almost being able to do plant
behavior which sounds
ridiculous but um you know that we've
we've got for instance just a red
huckleberry deciduous huckleberry right
off our deck
um that's actually huge now and it was
so
bowed down under ivy that you couldn't
tell and it didn't fruit at all and
um you know i uncovered that maybe a
year and a half ago now and last year
it put out a lot of um it put out a lot
of leaf and i'm hoping we get flowers
this year which means
um seed set and fruits by next summer
and you know it was it was just about
the ivy it was just about it being
buried
under this invasive species yeah and
there's so many places where
eucalyptus is the uh the it's not one
species but
is the the clade that is causing the
devastation the andes are
completely screwed up by by
eucalyptus which was brought in because
it makes a very fine
kind of lumber but anyway it's an
invasive that gets away from
people who are cultivating it so yeah
same thing looking at across andean
landscapes like
it's eucalyptus it's like looking into
portland forest
i'm seeing ivy i'm not seeing portland
forest i'm seeing eucalyptus i'm not
seeing
andean landscapes it's heartbreaking
yeah
all right first question from last hour
it looks like this is
in three parts but i'm not sure it's
three questions
if science research is publicly funded
how will you prevent its gaming capture
and corruption
would this not simply create an official
ministry of truth and another tool for
government to impres
to oppress people trust the experts or
else
um oh actually this that's
okay so that's one question then the
next two are two different questions
okay
yeah i don't think i think the idea
this is too simple you're not going to
publicly fund it and suddenly have it be
clean there's a culture of corruption in
which people who don't even know that
it's what they're doing
are trying to figure out um
what the viewpoints are that are
remunerative and so you know that
corruption is throughout
the system and public funding is not
a solution in and of itself what you
need is an incentive structure
where you are rewarded for being correct
and farsighted
over the long term right if you do that
then people will compete to discover
what's true
um but yeah no in isolation public
funding
um won't do it it's one one piece of a
much larger solution
yeah a lot more to say on that but let's
move on
i feel that automated unemployment is
another individual versus collective
action problem
new job sectors won't help the veteran
truck driver for instance who knows
nothing else and can't be retrained
because of moore's law
science and the arts will be
oversaturated driving wages down
and what happens in our brave new world
when the robots build
design and repair themselves i'd say
utopia if not
for the calhoun experiments crisis
question mark i don't know what the
calhoun experiments are
oh i think i do okay um it doesn't
matter
well yeah i don't think it's necessary
let's see if
mouse utopia shows up yep um
so these are circumstances where uh
mouse colonies were given everything a
mouse could want and they became
absurd and self-destructive and the mice
did yeah
um so uh
right right yes and this is part of the
logic in
this question or a pair of questions is
um in part what underlies
game b style thinking or called fourth
frontier
which is that if you follow our current
trajectory
to its logical conclusion it will result
in tremendous paradoxes like large
fractions of the population being
unnecessary
for uh the continuance of society and
therefore
um one needing either some sort of
massive
program to uh to replace what would have
been their wages or the acceptance of
uh them as uh you know outside of the
economy in some way homeless or
otherwise
so the basic point is look this got us
so far
but we're about to run off the end of
the tape the logic has come to its
natural end and we have to replace this
with something
in which either we redirect
how the economy pays you
and for what so that it pays you for
things that you can actually
do that enhance the well-being of
society or we have to decouple
your let's say well-being at the wealth
level
from your productivity as a worker
right that was not initially what human
beings uh were about and it doesn't have
to be that way permanently but you have
to do
something if you just simply imagine
that this system is great because look
what it did for us
and then you continue to play this game
it will result in
huge paradoxes and tremendous amounts of
unnecessary misery
fabulous i mean excellent answer oh so
you like
yeah unprecedented misery huh yeah
that's what i like that's what i said
you heard it here first the washington
establishment has reasserted its ugly
head
while strengthening its ties to big deck
challenging the official narrative and
white center
censorship are we going to look more
like china in four to eight years
um i you want to be careful with that
last conclusion right that's that's the
leap there i mean
i agree with the first two parts i would
say
we are going to reinvent some of the
things that
china does in one way in a very
different way and in fact we already are
right so the big tech whether it knows
it or not
is creating an alternative social credit
system
um that will be used and abused in ways
that i believe are every bit as
frightening as what china
is already doing yep and um does that
mean we'll
look more like china no it could be that
we look very different
um you know we could look as different
as
communism and fascism look from each
from each other on the other hand
two authoritarian systems do have an
analogy between them
and you know so let's not be so precise
that we miss what's actually going to
occur
yes yes with biden rejoining the paris
agreement cancelling the keystone
pipeline xl pipeline and reversing
arctic drilling rights do you have that
too
could we not say planetary triage wise
that we definitely have the much lesser
of two evils in the seat
love you too um
uh assuming assuming that we don't get
into
a global war and i think i think biden's
more likely to get us into
into that situation uh which could
obviously destroy everything
um but certainly with regard to
um to environmental protections that are
are bigger than just the u.s even um
lesser of two evils yeah i'd go with
that uh i'm not ready to do that and the
reason
look um
there are lots of things about a biden
administration
that are going to be better they just
simply are right
the pettiness is likely to be
gone the chances of a
completely out of left field strategic
blunder that you know
stumbles us into something unforeseen
is probably lower on the other hand
intentional war is is more likely
unintentional wars
gone down intentional war is more likely
the undermining of
the uh of the fundamental american
values on which our system
depends by kowtowing to
woke ideology actually has an almost
unlimited potential downside all right
if you take america apart
by playing americans off against each
other so that they don't go after elites
then what is likely to happen is going
to
uh is going to unseat the united states
from its position of global power which
leaves a vacuum that could be filled by
china russia some combination thereof
some
new emerging power and the danger of
that
to all of the values that you would
point to the paris agreement the
keystone xl pipeline arctic drilling etc
the uh net effect could be negative and
so
um i think the lesser evil
paradigm is just simply broken it's not
uh
it is not um game theoretically stable
in other words it becomes a weapon that
keeps you in line
um by uh showing you an
ever more corrupt regime and getting you
to vote for it because there's something
even scarier on the outside
so you know that's uh one thing but it
also
is not complex systems aware
right that lesser evil could be the
thing that actually undoes the system
whereas uh you know despite the
um the dangers of it things that are not
party to that lesser evil
um trading back and forth of power
may be the route out you know and i
don't like
yep either mode but i would just say you
can't do the net analysis and know
where you are you can say that there are
some things that this administration is
much less likely to do as far as putting
us in danger and there are other things
that it is almost certainly more likely
to do
next question would you please consider
reaching out to euron brook
regarding capitalism recently on your
appearance with zubi you said things
about capitalism that according to my
understanding was a mischaracterization
of capitalism
i don't totally know who erin brooke is
uh i do
um you know i'm willing to talk to euron
brooke but i also
think that this is you know i think what
i've said about capitalism
is that i reject challenges to it
because it is ill-defined
and to the extent that anybody is
challenging capitalism and meaning
to challenge the role of markets i think
they're dead wrong
the fact is markets are the most
powerful tool we have
to discover solutions but the problem is
that we put them not only in charge of
figuring out how to do things which
they're very good at
but we also put them in charge of
figuring out what to do which they are
absolutely appalling at
so i think that formulation
is right i'm open to having it
challenged and i'm certainly
you know ready to listen and respond to
that challenge
as to whether or not i have just
defended or attacked capitalism
i don't care yeah the the the uh the
analysis is what's important and i don't
i don't have a dog in the fight
either way with respect to that term
great
i'm curious about schools being forced
to move away from dress codes as they
are sexist or slut-shaming
is there a valid reason to have a dress
code in an educational environment
so i think the first part of this
sentence means
uh schools can't use are are being
forced away from dress codes because the
dress codes are claimed to be sexist or
slut-shaming
right this is um this is sort of
a third wave feminist interpretation of
what a dress code does
which is uh it puts the
burden on the would-be victim of being
observed and uh and possibly groped
and all of this as opposed to putting
the responsibility firmly on
the boys who would be doing the
observing
i think there's more to it than that i
think the claim is
that um more provocative
clothing is endemic to certain
populations and not
others and therefore the burden of a
dress code falls harder on
oppressed people is well that's a
different thing right
this is this is about sexism and sledge
this is about the male female dynamics
is what this question is about what
you're talking about is adding the
intersectional
a bit around um around oppressed classes
um basically socioeconomic class and and
often which is correlated with race
yeah right so that that is that is also
one of the reasons that is trotted out
for
the abandonment of dress codes i believe
but it's not what this one is this is
about
um basically uh girls should be
able to the
a caricature of the point is girls
should be able to wear whatever they
want including almost nothing at all
and if boys look that's on them because
um none of this is inherently sexualized
it's the act of looking by the boys that
sexualizes female body parts
um which is a stupid position
it's nonsense i mean it's nonsense right
down to the
biologically factual nonsense in light
of
female body parts that males are fond of
being
evolutionary displays of
sexual sexually selected unique to
humans all of this
yeah yeah so is there a validate to the
second part of the question
is there a valid reason to have a dress
code in an educational environment
yeah absolutely i say that as someone
who never had one
and whose children have never had them
and you didn't
um i went to one school in which there
was
a dress code but it was not onerous it
was there was no there was no uniform
yeah it was it was it just
prevented science shirts with colors
that kind of thing yeah um
um and so you know it hasn't it hasn't
become personal for us ever um and i
think it would have felt
frankly for me i think it would have
felt i would have had to contend with it
more deeply if it had been our kids
rather than if i had just sort of been
slotted into a situation where
i found myself with a dress code given i
didn't really care much about clothes as
a kid and like okay
as long as i don't have to wear a skirt
like you know and actually but that is
the kind of dress code that a lot of
at least um religious schools would have
would have imposed um potentially uh
which
you know effectively limits activity you
know that those
those sorts of dress codes where like
girls have to wear skirts and boys have
to wear like suits and ties
actually limits uh physical activity and
does reinforce traditional gender norms
especially with regard to skirts for
girls where you can't do
you know you're not going to play upside
down in the jungle gym if you're wearing
a skirt right
so you know those those sorts of things
um
are regressive um but
um basically asking for a certain amount
of coverage um
so there can it can be easier for
everyone to focus
on what it is that they are in school to
do academically as opposed to on the
social aspects of it i think
i think i think i could make an argument
for that i've not ever
tried exactly but i think there's one to
be made i'd go a little bit further even
that there's something to neutralizing
the effort um that goes into competing
um you know via clothing and you know
there's certainly
something to be said for self-expression
but the idea that
you're going to go to school and this is
not an issue for anybody because it's
against the rules for everybody you're
all wearing the same thing
i think is probably as much as that
seems
kind of old world um i think there's a
strong argument for it because
yeah no it obscures class differences
yeah right it
yeah you know if if you're at some
school that requires a dress code and
you've got
whatever two of them yeah you know like
regardless of whether or not that's all
you got in your closet at home
you come to school looking the same way
as the
kid whose family has a boat right
um so um yeah it potentially
does begin to get at equalizing the
playing field
yep no it's uh it does equalize it in in
a way that i think is
is important now as for whether or not
there
is evidence of what happens whether the
two environments are
really different i don't know right and
certainly there are ways of gaming it
you know
yeah the movie trope of you know girls
hiking their skirts up higher
uh despite the fact that it's part of a
uniform is
well understood but um this next one is
just a
um a link see here for a review of stats
and studies on trans violence
um and i did link it if i can figure out
where it is
oh boy um this is it's hard for me to
navigate my computer in this form that
we currently got it because it's so tiny
on my screen
um
but come on uh so zach if you just want
to show this very quickly this is just
um someone i
i did not have an opportunity to look
yet
pseudonym uh on medium the transgender
movement and bad stats a debunking
compilation
and my you know 10 seconds looking at it
looks like exactly that
they have collected a bunch of these bad
statistics or these statistics that are
commonly trotted out like you know
increased suicide rate for trans teens
and such
and and tried to drill down on them and
it looks like for the most part
found yeah no evidence so that's that's
good i'm going to
spend some time with that can you guys
look into or address the pfizer
israel deal from what i've seen it looks
like pfizer is giving vaccine doses in
exchange for israel's patient data
seems fishy i don't know anything about
this yeah
i only know um that israel is uh
supposedly a model in terms of its
effectiveness at delivering vaccines i
believe i've
read that though i didn't see this
question coming so i didn't look deeply
into it yeah
um but uh yeah we could look into that
uh was rachel levine born a male
question mark yes
yes but she was not born a man
[Music]
um actually i would point out can you go
back uh
which yeah was rachel levine born a male
uh i would point out that a measure
of the absurdity of where we have landed
can be
found and i can't swear that this will
be the same for you if you try it today
as it was for me a few days ago
when i went to wikipedia but if you look
up
rachel levine's history it does not make
any sense because while it is obvious
and acknowledged on the page
that she is a transgender female
the um page is written
as this as if this was a
um a revelation of a
permanent internal state which of course
is an argument you could make but it's
not one that
that wikipedia should be trafficking in
the fact is this is somebody
who lived as a male was married as a
male had children as a male
played football playing football college
football
transitioned to female and as it is
with um uh with chelsea
manning and uh you might
check out her uh wikipedia page too
but there is also a just a simple
um destruction of historical fact where
um it is reported that chelsea manning
gave
uh classified information
to wikileaks which she did not she was
bradley manning at the time
and the fact is the idea that somehow a
site
whose whose reason for being is
to record factual information so that
anybody can find
that such a site should be
doing anything other than reporting the
actual facts which is that bradley
manning handed over the documents was
sentenced
transitioned while in prison now is no
and it's
i mean this is this is the part where
they're just asking
we are being collectively gaslit
rachel levine's wikipedia page under
personal life she has two children david
and dana
she transitioned in 2011. levine and her
ex-wife martha pisley levine divorced in
2013.
and i believe it does not say that
suggests um now it doesn't say
genetic children it doesn't say that
rachel is the
genetic mother of the children but
their mother is listed here the ex-wife
and you know it's just not
possible that two eggs got together and
made these babies that's not what
happened
there was sperm involved and it came
from rachel
which means rachel is their dad and
therefore was a man that's just
really basic biology and the sentences
that are written here
don't don't come together they're
written they don't work
too obscure it's gaslighting as you say
they're written to obscure
the truth and in fact it feels we're
looking at the
page now um rachel levine is reported to
have been
born on october 28 19
is that say 67 57 57.
um so that's just factually inaccurate
right and the fact that it says levine
it says levine was born october 28 1957
and is originally from wake from
massachusetts
so okay again constructed so as
to uh create the ambiguity
where did no i'm talking about over
there anyway i think i think it is there
but
um these things look
let's see well i mean like where's she
trained in pediatrics you know all of
this
yeah where she yeah if you go back into
the career history and the early life it
doesn't add up
um and we are simply we are expected to
do the work
on the user side of putting together
what must have happened
and an obvious question like um you know
uh when did rachel levine uh transition
which is just a simple factual question
a journalist might want to answer
can't be established here well i mean
the date is listed here
um separately from that wapo article
that i shared in the first hour from
2016 we are told that
she won't say whether or not she's had
surgery or is on any
cross-sex hormones at all and she has
fathered two children
um that's that's a pretty solid group of
facts right there for me say there is
there is no way
that i should be expected to refer to
the person who was growing up
and who had children and who trained as
a pediatrician
um as if that person was a woman all
along
so no it to me this is exactly
parallel to if we attempted to
erase the distinction for women who
married and changed their
names if we pretended that
when you married you were simply
fulfilling your destiny to be with this
other person and adopt their name and
therefore you really had their name
since you were born
and we obscured your man's game
right it'd be exactly the same thing and
the answer is we don't do that why not
because it makes it really hard to
figure out what happened oh this person
is the same as that person here's her
maiden name
also as you acquire new identities new
truths about yourself
that does not change history right this
this thing is about
this this movement the activist part of
this movement and
not you know not all trans people yes
true 100
is about obscuring history it's it's a
there's a pretense here that by wishing
it to be
so you can time travel and recreate
things that already happened history
happens it happens
once there is objective reality to it
two different viewers on a particular
scene can have different interpretations
of it
but this person had children
genetic children with a woman who
gestated them and gave birth
to them i'm guessing at a few parts of
that here therefore this person
was male at the time but you shouldn't
have to guess wikipedia has an early
life and education
career it should all be here and i is
that can you put up uh
your mom's screen here so if you look on
the right side of this wikipedia page it
does say
rachel levine was born october 28 1957.
at the top it says rachel levine and
then it says where she was born
so that is the same thing that they do
with uh
chelsea manning having delivered uh
uh classified documents to julian
assange and wikileaks it's not
true yeah um so uh
this has obviously become a corrosive
influence on our ability even to figure
out what
basic facts are that should be
completely uncontroversial it is no
threat to rachel levine's
right to be rachel levine to acknowledge
that she
was born male yeah right it's no threat
it's just simply a fact
yep just over 50 minutes
okay um there's just a few comments here
that um i want to get through before we
switch to
this hour um this one actually so
biden quote we're going to crush the
virus also biden
from january 22nd quote there's nothing
we can do to change the trajectory of
the pandemic in the next several months
i feel like so i get what the person
who's writing this comment is doing
they're saying there's inconsistency at
on this very important topic i do think
that that second part of that quote has
been widely taken out of context
um that i believe and i wouldn't know
where to find it i only saw it once and
i was out in the world and i was like
looking at my phone
but the full quotation from him has him
sort of
not slurring but like mumbling a little
bit at first where he says like unless
we can do something
then yada yada yada and there's nothing
we can do to change the trajectory of
the pandemic in the next several months
i believe that that's what that's what
the actual full quote is
and if i'm wrong i'm sorry but i don't i
think that this
particular thing that i've seen a few
times is an unfair
assessment of what um what he's claiming
even as presented those two things are
not inconsistent
we're going to crush the virus doesn't
say when there's nothing we can do to
change the trajectory of the pandemic in
the next few months
um so i agree this is uh
um much to do about nothing yeah
i might be in the minority but i agree
with rand paul in this one i'm all for
treating people with respect and dignity
but government coercion typically does
way more harm than good in these areas
so this is going to be i think i think
this is going to be trans stuff again
well i think it it's a general point and
i i
must say i don't know rand paul's
position if it's
if it lines up with what's stated here i
am more or less in agreement which is to
say
um forcing people to speak in a
particular way
is not an effective way of dealing with
their bigotry it's liable to make it
worse
and yeah um that the successes we have
had have not come from
you know wagging fingers at people yeah
come from structural reforms that have
placed people
in circumstances they couldn't have
gotten to with
you know prior barriers and then
exposure
does the heavy lifting so you know yes
the the idea that we're going to police
speech into utopia is
nonsense now i will say somebody's going
to take me to task
for being such a stickler about the term
theory versus hypothesis is it going to
be me
no i don't think so um but i uh
i i accept that i am the only person who
is exercised about this at least at the
level
i care i just don't think every moment
is the time for the conversation
my well we have a convenient example in
the last
week where a journalist who actually did
a decent job of
covering the lab league hypothesis for
cnet
started with the title and it's you know
titles are sometimes written not by the
author in fact often not really
yeah almost always um but you know the
title says the lab leak theory
and that terminology goes through the
entire piece and there's just this
question about
a the entire fact that we are now
talking in rational terms about the lab
leak possibility the lab leak
explanation
and whether or not it is correct
that is the result of very hard work
on the part of people who have been very
careful not to overstate the case
and in one piece of journalistic
carelessness a whole lot of good is
going to be undone because once again
we're now subject to the idea
that we are conspiracy theorists when in
fact we had successfully
um shut down that false accusation by
being careful so anyway i do think it's
important
but in that case it is not that we want
to police people's language to make them
better it's that we want the language to
actively reflect the rules of engagement
a hypothesis is different than a theory
right if you
disbelieve the theory of evolution
it's not always the time to talk about
it right because
it is a theory it is well established
and if you want to go to an evolution
conference and
have that battle you know we don't have
to listen but
when it comes to hypotheses we know what
the rules are right they're evidentiary
rules they're well established and
that's where we should be so
language matters but policing people's
language to make
them change their moral stance is not
gonna work
awesome okay three quick comments before
we switch to this
this hours question 64
our friend holly reminds us is both a
perfect square
and perfect cube swoons wow
yeah yeah that's awesome four cubed
eight squared uh brilliant podcast as
always greetings from somerset uk here's
my door fee
thank you for that and i love every one
of you and hope you all have a wonderful
day today
thank you for that as well thank you so
much and
let me see where all right
um oh what is going on
so zach i am oh there we go um
no i know there's a line i just am i've
lost control of my
i don't know what's going on okay
why says the first question from this
hour's
questions why are women so much more
likely to love horses than men
i work as an equine artist and in three
years i have never had a male client
i am also a horse obsessed woman so very
intrigued
thanks thank you for clarifying
um as what well what did you say about
uh equine artist ah
yes so you thought it might have been a
horse riding in or someone who
identified as one but
she clarifies that in the later part of
the question i'm
glad to have it clarified so we don't
have to wonder what a relief
yeah all right um that
it's gotten it's gotten that absolutely
it's gotten there yes it's gotten there
it's we're
almost three hours in okay um yeah so
all right why
why are women and girls more
likely to be fond of
horses and i do wonder if this was
always the case
[Music]
there may be you know
when horses were
animals taken into battle yeah
presumably
the relationship of men to their horses
would have been different
yes um so certainly dothraki women
don't have a particularly close
relationship with the horses it seems
yes dothraki women to the extent
that they exist which they don't right
um yeah so i i'm i'm not entirely
sure yeah i don't i don't have anything
good on this i mean it's and i
i guess i would like to know in order to
posit a hypothesis here i'd like to know
the history of how widespread it is like
is it just the u.s
or is it across the weird world and how
long ago
you know does this start in the 50s
in the u.s or even you know post-war
boom times
and um you know i
i still don't have an answer off the top
of my head if that's when it starts but
i don't
without knowing you know is it a
victorian era thing
um i think i think we need more
information in order to
to get at it i mean
you know on average women and girls are
more likely to be interested
in you know systems that are human or
animal
and men and boys are more likely to be
interested in systems that are
things objects numbers um so
that doesn't get you anywhere close
really except that you might predict
if the horse if the horse girl horse
woman thing
is real um that you would also find
um that girls are more driven to have a
pet
at home right that um that that is that
is similar and you know of course we
have this trope of you know boy and his
dog
um and that presumably goes back farther
into you know into hunting times again
but that having an animal that you don't
that you can love unequivocally and who
loves you unequivocally
back but whom is not doing a job for you
is a pretty novel circumstance right
like it's it's a total luxury to have
to have the people wolves and uh epic
tabby that we do
right um they they they serve no
function but
but love and companionship don't let
them hear you i think they know i think
the dog anyway is actually perturbed by
this the dog desperately would like to
be functional would like a job the cats
are
quite happy the way things are thank you
very much yeah that's fair
yeah yep all right so i'm not sure we
no we didn't got to an answer but um and
i the next one from echo um i
quickly looked this up i don't do dune
question is how it starts i love dune
i've only read the first book though no
that's not true i read the second book
and it was so disappointing that i
didn't read any of the rest
um what's your take on chair dogs
well chair dogs weren't in either the
first two books so i don't know
feasible ethical same question about
axolotl tanks and other
that's both tiny and probably in dune
language
uh tilaksu something merch uh
p.s did you know that herbert was into
jungian psychology i did know that
um you know super interesting weird guy
but then you know
yeah he's into a lot of weird stuff um
do you know anything about chair dogs
no i don't so that's two questions in a
row we can't really answer sorry
uh which of these do you believe has
lifted more people around the world out
of poverty
capitalism globalism democracy
public education and safety nets or the
empowerment of women
wow wow um yeah i would say
i mean some of them are contingent on
others right that's the problem is
they're non-independent yeah they're not
independent so
you know both public education and
safety nets and the empowerment of women
are probably inherently downstream of
democracy
and maybe of capitalism as well i mean i
think i could
i think i could take globalism off the
list i would be tempted to as well
although
there's an argument to be made on the
other hand it sort of forces you
into a okay define poverty right
um yeah so and you know you need
you need some amount of globalism for
you know democracy here to spread over
there
and thus you know give some education to
women so they can be empowered and so
that they can you know the birth rate
can go down and they can
accrue more wealth etc yeah um so
you know it's a good list and even even
the one that that i am most willing to
say it's not that one
has a role to play here so most um
well no yeah more people around the
world i
i think it's a ranked list i think i
think you just can't do them
independently
yep and there's also the possibility
that
there are things on it that you really
you know the spirit of the question is
completely inconsistent with the idea
that um things like
war famine
deadly pandemic diseases result in
uh consequences that may be economically
positive for those who survive
these things so um anyway
wow is a complex question um yeah no i
mean like
none of these things are in the black
death left um
a lot of open niches it left a lot of
wealth on the surface
and resulted in an increase in
well-being for those
who are around to participate in that
and early on most of them were
in deep mourning but but they're they're
those who survived left descendants who
were better off
largely um
i've had some success waking up my mom
and aunt to what is happening
however my brother and his wife are
frogs in the pot
any advice on reaching them get them to
wear lapels
you used to tell there was we had we had
one student whom we adored
and who was just hard to get to do what
he needed to do and you
finally told me tell him to just wear
lapels all the time
and because we had this kind of
relationship i i did and i
and i grabbed him by them he was
gigantic like six foot sexy
anyway it didn't work it still didn't
work but i got to grab them by the
lapels
right yeah um so yeah i think we need to
know more
about your brother and his wife right
like i mean you've told us something
that's
important which is that you are able to
talk with some members of your family
such that you can convey some truth and
reality to them
and the scales may be beginning to fall
from their eyes awesome
that means that you have the wherewithal
to make
careful nuanced compassionate arguments
with people
you know with whom you share a history
and presumably
love um you know
sibling relationships look all sorts of
ways
and not knowing what your history with
your brother is
it would even help to know frankly if
you're the older brother the younger
brother if you have other siblings
um you know what the what the
relationship with the wife is like both
yours and his
um but you know absent absent any of
those particulars
you got any you got any approaches that
he may not have thought of this you know
this i'll fight you naked guy
who um who has been able to successfully
talk to other family members
um well i don't know we don't get enough
hate mail so
you could point over the dark horse
podcast there's always that approach
um yeah i mean look
there's a question about the the time
scale
right and are you making headway but
it's slow enough that you don't register
it can you make predictions about what's
coming
that are sufficiently careful that when
the things that you think are going to
come to pass
do and your brother has told you that he
doesn't believe that they will
that he will recognize that there was
something about your model that
uh carried the truth and can he do that
like will he follow through
on oh you predicted this um
wow that's i didn't i was sure that
wouldn't come to pass and you predicted
it
yeah so things along those lines yeah
okay
love you guys wondering if you've ever
heard of the venus project would love to
hear your thoughts or pass it to eric
for his commentary
i have not no nope i have not either
from texas heading to mount hood among
many of the other oregon attractions in
april
um cool um that aside what do you think
the future of game b
is gus well i guess uh
the thing is game b
you probably should look into uh there's
a couple of
pieces on it jim rutt has done some
on his podcast rebel wisdom has done a
bit on game b
um my perspective is that game b hasn't
jordan written a couple of things
on his medium jordan hall jordan i think
a couple of really
really good pieces but i would say this
distills down to
an understanding that once you see it is
inescapable
right that the structures that run
civilization put us on a fatal
trajectory
that they are very strong but also
fragile and not competitively
superior in other words there is
inferiority
that against an honest competitor would
result in game a failing once you've
seen that then the question is
not game b itself it's not an
organization
it's not a particular plan it's a
recognition that something must come
next and that that something can be what
naturally emerges at the failure
of what we've got which is likely to be
a disaster and maybe not a survivable
one
or it can be something architected to
succeed at what we value
better than our current system does and
so the question is
how you know it'd be great if there were
20 40
100 game b uh projects
targeted at figuring out what the next
system looks like yeah
only one needs to succeed and the
problem is there are too few of them
and the likelihood is we won't find the
viable
uh formulation in time but
um the answer is yeah it's game b or
bust
yeah and and if you haven't um
looked at some of jordan's stuff i would
just put this up briefly zach
um just on medium search on jordan hall
um and you'll find uh some of his stuff
and uh looks like he hasn't published
anything since
july of last year he's got the rise and
fall of networks
defunded redesigned everything and his
thinking is always
very very careful reliably
and surprising okay
i'm so liberal i not only believe in
universal health care but i think
registered pets should be part of the
package
do you think the next big hurdle is
proper rights for animals and the
environment
um no for
the following reason
it's a very tough sell and it is not
obvious
how you would uh properly
value these things on the other hand
if you say what matters is human
well-being
and it's not living humans it's as many
humans as we can give as liberated
a life as we can provide them the gift
of
a liberated human life being the
ultimate thing that we have to offer
the planet has to be stabilized
in other words our system has to become
sustainable in order
to provide an indefinitely large number
of generations
uh a world if the world is being
degraded every generation then
that's a short-term plan if it is stable
that's an indefinitely long plan that's
the way to
give that gift to the maximum number of
humans and if you recognize
that that is a worthy goal
you will actually end up generating
systems that protect the very values
you're talking about
without having to defend them
independently right
in other words um a world in which there
are no more orcas
is a degraded world it's not a
sustainable world
right so do we need to award orca's
status and in which case how do we do it
i don't know
do we want to say actually the value of
orcas to humans is such that they must
be protected
and therefore we must evaluate policy
relative to its ability to do that for
human well-being purposes
that we can do i'm not sure about this
and i don't have an answer i'm not sure
i think the problem is uh
if you try to implement any alternative
plan you'll discover why they don't
work yeah uh it feels to me like this
could like what you were suggesting and
i know that you and i share
the actual values and underlying goals
but it feels like this
that could be uh used
to create a explicitly anthrocentric
world in which um only humans
yeah are are considered of value and you
know that there are those there
are there are those who actually really
believe
um that um we can live absent
uh the world that the vast majority of
us and our ancestors have
grown up in of course but who are they
to tell somebody five generations from
now that a decision was made that
they're not entitled to have orcas on
their planet
but then but then it feels to me that
it's easier to defend
the value of orcas in their own right
then
the value of work is in my mind like
what what does me
valuing me having like putting amenity
value on orcas
uh do it's you know it's inherently
unquantifiable
right but the problem is if you well i
don't know that it's inherently
unquantifiable it's inherent
that it will be arbitrary which is part
of the point
now my point is look i think we need to
be
free to drive anopheles mosquitoes to
extinction and not free to drive orcas
to extinction
um one can do not actually free to drive
all mosquitoes to extinction either
right anopheles being the genus of
mosquitoes that vectors
malaria dengue zika yellow fever others
right and so my point is if we just take
the simplifying assumption
that what we are doing is trying to
um provide the
maximally hospitable world for the
maximum number of generations over which
we can have
an impact we can do that calculation
without having
to reckon with the right of anopheles
mosquitoes to continue
which of course if orcas do then it's
really an aesthetic choice
to say that monopolies mosquitoes don't
um so my point is the reason i prefer
this
i mean i i i am i am an aesthetic choice
or you know people have tried to do this
on the basis of consciousness
on the basis of social structure right
and my point
of life i can just hear the sound effect
of the car
accident that comes from each of these
choices the only one that doesn't result
in that sound effect is to say you know
what
this is about human well-being but it
can't be about
us living humans at the expense of
future humans it's about them
every bit as much as it's about us and
to whatever degree we start degrading
the planet so they get less of one
that's our screw up and we're not
entitled to it i guess how do how
then how though do we defend against the
elon musks
you know the super powerful dudes who
actually think that life on mars would
be a way for humans to live
uh we don't i mean for one thing uh
elon it's a hard road
um i hope you succeed i'm not
going red rocks are cool
maybe for a week but mars is going to be
a
very boring place even if you terraform
mars
it's going to be you know you think
portland is bad because of the
the ivy mars is going to take ivy to
mars yeah
mars is gonna be appalling even
terraformed right that doesn't mean it
wouldn't be
beautiful like to glimpse out a window
you could but
you know maybe you could but if you did
the point is there's no richness to it
because it's not a natural
biological planet or at least it hasn't
been on in a very long time
so anyway i'm not against
uh elon hedging our bets by getting
something going on mars that's a good
idea
i don't think it's anything to bank on i
would say the same
thing about eric's point about uh
breaking the einsteinian speed limit
hey cool let's do that if we can but i
don't think anybody should be treating
that
as plan b it's not right right
plan b has to be how do we break this
system
from doing its destructive thing and
replace it with a system that does not
degrade the planet one generation to the
next
right that's just simply a i believe
it's philosophically robust
and b i believe it is the one thing that
we can
say that is objective sufficiently
objective that we could actually pursue
it
and bonus i think all the things that
you want to come out of
an attempt to grant nature rights or
whatever
fall out of that naturally rather than
having to be artificially erected on top
of some
uh unstable philosophical ground
maybe
i hear you it makes me very nervous
sure yeah we're in a predicament you
should be nervous yeah well this person
uh writes a follow-up question saying
p.s i have a koala skull if you are
interested
um you know of course we're interested i
suspect that they
are illegal to take out of australia um
i actually are koalas societies
qualities must be cities listed
societies
stands for uh i don't know cited stands
for something
cities is the set of international law
um that describes the that's not it at
all
that describes the level of protection
of particular animals
societies one two or three and i um
species how about that
it's coming up with something random um
society stands for um
it's not telling me um i don't even know
i don't know what it stands for um
anyway
if qualizer societies listed which i
think it they must be
um you can't
it's probably illegal to have them you
know people end up with skulls
um but the convention on international
trade and endangered species
of wild fauna and flora it's an
international agreement between
governments
and um it's good and actually does
restrict
illegal pet trade and um and
such and even if
it's legal with permits
to have them within a country if your
site is listed at all i think you can't
trans
transform across borders which means
that anything that appears to be
anything like that
is at risk of being searched and seized
um
at the border and anyway it's a
it's a big mess you know of course we
want to call a skull but um
it's a huge um
likely legal problem
yeah um i don't know what this next
question means
do primates owe chiropterans something
better than cavendish
if so should probably figure out
preferred cultivars
hope they're good for smoothies
it's cavendish primates are primates
pyrapterons or bats
not quite sure you could look up
cavendish see if you
might look attempt to look up cities
which distinctly
um yeah that's going to come up with
a bunch of different cabin dishes so
that's not really going to help
yes well then i think the answer is an
unequivocal yes okay
excellent um let's do maybe
three more
um hi brett why are the meta analyses
done on implicit bias so rarely
mentioned
all of them show negative results and
there's a link to something from
annual review um
yeah brett why yeah why are you ignoring
the meta-analysis well i think for the
same reason that we do all kinds of
other shoddy things in order to advance
policies that um are not well supported
by evidence
oh wait hold on so second part of this
question that link is from the latest
published article
on january 4th of this year quote we
conclude that much research effort is
theoretically and empirically ill-suited
to provide actionable evidence-based
recommendations for reducing prejudice
great quote yeah i mean the whole
landscape around this is so
messed up you know if
implicit buy it bias tests work
then we ought to be able to use them to
test
out of implicit bias training
right yeah implicit bias training is
being wielded as a weapon
and the idea is oh uh it
is both necessary because it works and
doesn't end and you can't test out
because it doesn't right right so
you know the whole thing is just
logically um
uh inconsistent
at a suspicious level yes so i think the
reason that they aren't mentioned
is because that would be even more
awkward than the inconsistencies that
are already staring us in the face
yeah okay uh zach what are we at
we must be well over now at this point
okay maybe this is the one to end on
what do you guys think about shrooms
and do you know of any ways to sober up
quickly i've been high all day
i'm sorry if you're if you'd rather not
be at this point
i'm sorry no i don't know um i don't
know any way to sober up just
quickly no yeah just you know do do
do steer away from mirrors and phones
yeah um but you're not alone
you're not alone it'll it'll end soon
yeah it's it always does that's i mean
that's
yeah if if if it's a bad trip you're on
know that it will always end it will
100 um and uh
you know find yourself a nice animal to
hang out with that often helps yeah um
no they're super interesting very
interesting yeah um i will say what i
always say which is
um great but not recreational
um doesn't mean you can't have a great
time but
these are very powerful tools and they
should be treated
with respect which means among other
things
pay very careful attention to
the circumstances in which you do them
i would say circumstances of trust
circumstances that are thought-provoking
that allow you uh freedom to
think quietly engage not engage
all those things are important in which
you are and you know that you are
actually physically safe yep yeah
yep all right maybe that's it okay
well so we will be back
in a week once again uh at the right now
um is the we're in the middle of the 48
hour um ask your question period
on my patreon for uh the private q a
which will happen
not tomorrow but next sunday at 11
pacific for a couple of hours uh join
join me there join brett on his patreon
if you'd like access to
um either of his monthly conversations
um
access i access the discord server on
either of them
uh we've got we've got merchandise for
sale
somewhere um what is it called store
can't find anything thank you that was
zachary
yeah that was zachary our producer our
16 year old son producer in the
background
informing me of the url which is
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
uh we may have some something new soon
there um email thedarkhorse.moderator
gmail.com for any logistical questions
you've got
and enjoy your week get outside
stay calm
try to do the science rather than just
trusting the experts
be well and if you're tripping it'll be
over soon and i hope it was great
[Music]
you